A lot of you have wondered where, and how you even buy liquid nitrogen.
Where do you even get it how much does it cost
whats the process
so today we're gonna go buy some liquid nitrogen
this little baby is a 35 liter liquid nitrogen dewar
this is basically a glorified thermos
that you use for storing liquid nitrogen
its got a little foam riser in here that help prevent the liquid nitrogen from coming out too fast
but at the same time it's got enough air gaps that any pressure can be released
and before i this thing i used this
this actually is a thermos i pick up at Walmart for like 5 or 10 dollars
i can't remember what but
that's the first container they let me take liquid nitrogen in and it does work
Lil more  dangerous of course but
it gets the job done
we're taking this thing together today
to go get some liquid nitrogen
alright so you may be wondering why I'm driving my Weiss minivan and...
well hey its awesome and it's got lots of room and it will store my nitrogen dewar no problem
i could stick 10 foot 2 x 4's from Home Depot
so i love our minivan but...
I think it's time to get my own car
you see 3 years ago I sold my car because all I do is sit at the computer editing videos
so i didn't really have a need for one
so i sold my car
I've been using the minivan but now I'm in a position where i wanna start traveling
maybe go to see some other youtubers around the country
and just have a little more freedom to do things like this
so... I need a new car
now this is what you wanna be looking for
something that sells industrial and medical gases
they're definitely gonna have liquid nitrogen here
alright I'm just gonna run in and talk to these guys for a second
I'm cutting my time a little bit short
cuz i have to pick my boy up from school in just a little bit
so I'm just mhm... I may just drop off this dewar
and have them fill it up while I'm gone
but I will get back to you
I'll let you know how much it cost and all the details and transactions
* Cameron says something
I appreciate that
just a.. met Cameron here
he says he's watched some of my videos before
Cameron: Yea
and so we were just lookin up this thing
you got the spacial muff and uh
I'm not sure how do you actually measure out the amount of liquid nitrogen
Worker: by weight
just by weight perfect
but anyway I'm cutting this a little bit short
I gotta go pick up my kid from school
so I'm gonna come back when this is all done and we'll grab it then
ok so apparently my kids on a field trip and wouldn't be back till 12:30
so i didn't need to rush quite as quickly as I did
but...
since we got a little bit of time to kill
I'm gonna show you how these numbers work for the liquid nitrogen
and basically give you the rundown of how much it cost and why
alright so when you go to buy liquid nitrogen here's basically how it works
refrigerated liquid nitrogen i got 20 Liters of it which you can see is...
they charge 4 dollars and 25 cents per liter
for a total of 85 dollars
and then we have a hazmat fee here
they charge another 4.50 for
so 89.50 plus tax gives me 95.63
and thats the cost of 20 Liters liquid nitrogen
we're right on guys
I'm back at home I've got my dewar about half full of liquid nitrogen
it's not nearly as heavy you think it would be
and if we take this thing out now you can see
it definitely is vaping a little bit
somehow i just broke my tripod just by adjusting the leg
and this ball popped right out the socket
i didn't even know they could do that
and I'm trying to get it back in but...
man I'm not that strong
I might have to send this back and get a new one
you guys wanna see what the liquid nitrogen actually looks like
Son 1: Yea
K come sit on this step over here
heres a little bit
Son 1: O gosh can i step on it
it kind of looks like a cloud on the ground
Son 1: Dadda I wanna
I'm gonna do a little bit more
Cameraman(Woman?): K
Cameraman(Woman?): watch out for your feet and stuff guys everybody stand back
Cameraman(Woman?): woah
thats so cool
look is like little beads
Cameraman(Woman?): Yea
dripping aroud huh
Cameraman(Woman?): Thats cool
Boy 1: I just stepped in it
how to make the ground fog